Tracy is starting off this our trace
rather in Florida hi trace how are you
all I've done better Dave who are you
better than I deserve what's up so I've
done over a half a million dollars in
debts including my business debts
I'm really scared I don't know if I need
to file for bankruptcy or if there's
something I can pull myself out as I
don't know it's gotten out of control
and I got stupid so I need to figure out
what my next move is how old are you I'm
25 you married yes you get children no
no no children okay so tell me what kind
of debt the $500,000 okay so I've got
trucks that total is about 300,000 I've
got two company pickup trucks those
equal about 75,000 actually one just got
repossessed yesterday morning in the
middle of the night
I've got equipment that totals to about
95 I've got accounts like for parts and
stuff that equals that to about 50,000
I've got student loans for 26,000
medical bills for about 600 $800 and my
miscellaneous stuff is about 2,500 which
includes you know so no the part is the
like you know a tractor trailer this 300
gram no no I it's for dump trucks that
I've got Oh for trucks okay
they're in the urine the earthmoving
business then yeah I do I do site work
and I'd be paving and all that good
stuff I see okay mm-hmm and your
business income has just not been enough
to support all this now
I mean we've we've grossed close to a
million that we spent one point but
about 1.3 already
we got cheated on a job
actually two jobs to the same guy in
June of July and I've leaned the
properties and I really don't have the
money to go after litigation suit you
know so I'm kind of just hoping I get
paid and so you know all the extra money
I've had coming in I spent it being
stupid you know buying equipment and I
really thinking about the ramifications
now it's kind of combating good bite me
in the butt and I'm just really scared I
don't know what to do okay so how long
ago did you start this it'll be five
years in pretty ray so you bought your
first truck or whatever on debt when you
were 20 years old
I would sell his $19 20 yes sir what was
the first thing you bought it was a dump
truck I started out with a dump truck
hauling material and stuff like that and
then from then on I started getting into
other scopes of work and buying
equipment okay
and what will the equipment sell for if
you sold it on the truck well I'm pretty
upside down Dave I like the trucks for
example I've done in finance that's what
I call gangster lenders you know and you
know there's so much interest on them
that I doubt I could sell them and get
back nearly what I have to pay them off
for and you know that's the scary part
as well so what was your best year of
net profit last year last year motions
are on brought in about just short of a
hundred thousand okay off of a cost of a
million me and a half gross well last
year it was about 400 ish so and then I
took that money and was stupid and spent
it on some more equipment yeah instead
of skating and paying off other debt
yeah okay well I mean there's two
possible three possible scenarios one
that use go simply go get enough work
lined up to pay these bills and begin to
pay down the debt and you get strength
you get squared around on this you sound
awfully hopeless on that possibility
just talking to you I don't have any
idea how much work you can gather in and
but I mean if you can bring based on
what you're telling me if you can bring
in six or eight hundred thousand dollars
of gross I think you can begin to not
only pay the bills but begin to reduce
the debt gradually in which case you're
not writing and in September we had a
dump thought was leaving the asphalt
plant and the bed was going up and he
had a bridge going 55 mile an hour and
destroyed the trucks and luckily nobody
was hurt but it cost me almost 20,000
out of my pocket just to clean up the
accident so my insurance immediately got
this you didn't have an assurance to
clean up the accident no I did but I had
to pay out of pocket initially until the
insurance so it didn't cost you it took
cash flow and then you got the money
back from the insurance company
right right so net that was not a
negative event net that was a break-even
yeah and you got rid of the truck right
yeah and they and they dropped you in
here to get different insurance yeah it
took me about a month so we really
couldn't even do anything
and I just like maybe about a month ago
I really started to get going again
so we're behind on everything and I was
I've been put in bits from work and some
of a lot of it doesn't begin until the
new years went on so it's a little bit
far out so I'm busy trying to keep busy
doing small stuff one of the ways you
can one of the ways you can turn the
corner and I don't know if you're going
to make it without bankruptcy
bankruptcies not going to solve your
problem less you're just going to walk
away I mean you just throw them all the
keys sound bankruptcy papers and walk
away that's what that would do and then
you're basically an unemployed 25 year
old that drives a dump truck yeah and
you start again that that's an option
okay the second thing you can do is you
can prioritize and say all right what is
the most important thing that I need
money for
food for you and your wife the second
most important thing that's lights and
water at your house what's the next most
important thing pay the rent of the
payment house payment at the house
so we take care of my own home first
those are some basic things you can make
enough to do that the money past that
then let's prioritize and say all right
which of these vehicles do we really
need to fight to keep and the other ones
we're going to try to sell but they may
repo them mm-hmm but the ones that we're
going to fight to keep are the ones that
we pay the payments on the ones we don't
fight to keep we can't pay them and
they're either going to take them or
we're going to get them sold or some
combination thereof and so you know you
could just say I'm gonna to pick dump
truck these two dump trucks and there's
one piece of equipment and that's what I
want to come out of this with and I'm
going to keep all of that current and
I'm gonna fight my way through and if I
can scratch and claw and make enough to
pay the other stuff I'm going to but I'm
gonna take care of my household first
the core set of equipment second and the
other ones the other things we're gonna
do if we can do them and you protect
your marriage sir you don't let this
stuff take your marriage hold on we're
going to put you in Financial Peace
University as my guest
[Music]